all right you
Mew oh where are you from originally
where did you grow up I am come from
Thailand I'm born in Bangkok and tell me
about your family growing up my horse
100 girl when I'm young I think I'm good
about five years old I think I am good I
don't think I am bored you know yes
because my heart 100 goal you never
thought you were a boy yes
did that cause problems in your family
yes my family is okay
you're okay with it yes
that's great okay
do you think that is more accepted here
in Thailand than other parts of the
world
in Thailand yes there are many yes trans
people here yes what was your childhood
like
I like to
party
you like to wait party yes what does
that mean sweet friend with friends yes
when did you start doing this kind of
work
I studied accounting
accounting accounting yes oh you went to
school for accounting
and you were going to be an accountant
yes
yeah and then I come to work in the bar
when did the bar work start I brought
about in about six four or six months